الان مع اطلاله على ابرز القضايا
والتفاعلات على منصات التواصل الاجتماعي
حصاد مقطع فيديو لاحد صناعي الفيديو في
الولايات المتحده حصد اكثر من 32 مليون
مشاهده المقطع يظهر فيه اليوتيوبر المعروف
باسم مستر بيست وهو يعلن عن حمله تمكن
خلالها من مساعده الف مكفوف او شبه مكفوف
على استعاده البصر بالتعاون مع احد جراح
العيون
النسبه اليوم
او شبه مكفوفين تمكنوا من استعاده بصرهم
بفضل مبادره قام بها صانع المحتوى ميدان
السن المعروف باسم مستر بيست بدا مستر
بيست المبادره بالتعاوني مع جراح العيون
جاف لبن سن المعروف بتوفير جراحات مجانيه
عدسه العين وليس لديهم تامين
صحيين والعيادات المجانيه لانشاء قائمه
بالمرضى الذين يحتاجون الى جراحه السد وهي
اجراء تزال فيه عدسه العين وتستبدل بعدسه
صناعيه في اغلب الحالات وتمكن اللبن سن من
اجراء الجراحات لاربعين مريضا في يوم واحد
اذن النصف المصابين بالعمى في عالم
يحتاجون الى عمليه جراحيه مدتها عشر دقائق
فقط بحسب لبن سن الذي يقول انه شاعر
بالصدمه من فكره ان هناك نحو مئتين مليون
شخص في العالم مكفوفون او شبه مكفوفين
بسبب اعدام عدسه العين ولا يستطيعون اجراء
الجراحه لعدم تمكنهم من تحمل تكاليفها
بمنظمه الصين انترناشونال غير الربحيه
التي تقدم رعايه مجانيه لمرضى العيون
المحتاجين في العالم
ساعدت المنظمه دونتسن في الوصول الى مزيد
من المرضى في كافه انحاء العالم كجمايكا
وهندوراس ولمبيا والمكسيك واندونيسيا
والبرازيل وفيتنام و كينيا ليصل العدد الى
الف عمليه جراحيه اجريت خلال ثلاثه اسابيع
يامل كل من
ان يلهم الفيديو الذي شاهده الملايين
المعنيين للمساعده في انهاء حالات من
العمى لا داعي لها طالما ان علاجها ممكن
ويسعيان الى الحصول على دعم حكومي وخاص
لانهاء النصف حالات العمى في العالم وهو
امر سيعود بمكاسب لا تصدق في الانتاجيه
والامكانات البشريه بحسب جراح العيون
[موسيقى]
وبدر جميله بالفعل
يعني سنطرحه الان على الدكتوره سحر خميس
من ميريلاند استاذه الاعلان في جامعه
ميريلاند دكتوره سحر ما الذي يجعل هذه
المبادرات تنجح يعني يحاول البعض ان يقوم
بمبادرات من هذا النوع تنجح مع البعض
وتفشل مع بعض الاخر ما هي العوامل العوامل
النجاح
لمبادارات من هذا النوع اللي صانع المحتوى
شكرا لكم على الاستضافه ربما تتحدث كثيرا
عن النواحي السلبيه لكثير من وسائل
التواصل الاجتماعي عندما نتحدث عن نشر
ربما المعلومات الكاذبه او المضلله او
احيانا الترفيه الغير مفيد خاصه عندما
يتعلق الامر به الشباب والمراهقين وصغار
السن ولكن ينبغي الا ننسى ان هناك ايضا
دور هام للغايه لوسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
هو ما يسمى بالسوشيال او المسؤوليه
الاجتماعيه المسؤوليه الاجتماعيه معناها
هذا الدور الذي ينبغي ان تقوم به هذه
المنصات الهامه ذات الشعبيه الواسعه والتي
تصل الى ملايين المشاهدين حول انحاء
العالم في محاولات ايصال رسائل مفيده وهذا
قيمه وطبعا هذا مثال واضح وصارخ لك كيفيه
استخدام هذه المنصات الناجح للقريه هذا
هذا بالنسبه للاستخدام بحد ذاته
للمنصات منصات التواصل لكن السؤال حتى من
يقصد ان
يقدم محتوى اجتماعي او خيري من هذا النوع
قد لا يصل الى الملايين كما حصل مثلا مع
مصر بيست السؤال عن عوامل النجاح اذا ما
اراد صنع محتوى ان ينجح في عمل من هذا
النوع
اعتقد ان عمليه ان يكون هناك ما يسمى
بالتفاعليه ان يكون هناك بالف
عل الصوت
كيف تجدين هذه التهمه التي توجه يوجهها
البعض لمستر بين
هذا
فقط اعتقد ان هذا
الان هو مثال جيد للغايه في القيام
بالمسؤوليه المجتمعيه او المسؤوليه
الاجتماعيه التي ينبغي ان يقوم بها
الاعلام عموما وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
خاصه بما لها من شعبيه وانتشار واسع جدا
اعتقد انه لم يستغل هؤلاء بالعكس وقدم
نماذج حيا نماذج واقعيه ناجحه استطاع ان
يصل فيها رساله هامه الى كل انحاء العالم
اذا كان لديك استطاع ان تقدم الخير وان
تمد يد العون للاخرين فلا تتردد لحظه
واحده ان تفعل ان هناك ملايين من ينتظرون
هذه الخدمات حول انحاء العالم ربما كانت
هذه
ايصال هذه الخدمات اليه شكرا
لك الدكتور صحر خميس استاذته الاعلام في
جامعه